all right guys we're in the pack exact  olympics here's the thing  the chinese have ten  chinese  [Music]  two three four  [Music]  six  [Music]  [Music]  okay one two three  four five six seven  get him  dude his leg was like one two  three  four  five  six seven eight nine  [Music]  nice  [Music]  chance to win the olympics guys okay  focus last round two  all right  get in count come on  [Music]  nice  [Music]  [Applause]  i thought about denying it but  there's a lot of misconceptions about  nab uh it's not just about radios  anymore there's this new kid in town  called computer software so recently  devin and ourselves got to shoot a video  together in minnesota and while we were  there he was telling me how they were  releasing a signature series